oh hello everyone ripping it out ripping it hello guys i'm
nervous as always i am nervous trust me oh another day
another tournament this looks like it's gonna be a hard team
as well oh so i hope everything will be okay
Yep, same format, Swiss format, but I think we got, we
definitely got matched with one of the harder team.
Teams are of the same record as us, judging by the ranks.
Oh, so I will try my best.
Yeah.
No, I'm just nervous.
It's not my sad voice.
I'm just really nervous in general.
Again, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I have to, I have to do it for the try hard.
I didn't get managed to practice a lot after the tournament
because I had to I had to make dinner um for myself because
um um I was like oh I have so much food I might as well make
some leftover make something to eat I should have ordering
out oh yeah so I didn't get to practice a lot I'm so behind
on behind the work too oh have luck good fun Zechariah thank
you the super chat thank you thank you oh so I'm I'm bundled
of nerves but it's also the first game so it's
understandable we can't lose a single game today if we want
to um make it to the finals so that's why i'm really nervous
because we have no we have no like uh pass anymore no passes
we just gotta go no get out of jail free car we just we just
gotta gotta do it so let me change it to full screen real
quick just to be sure uh simple minded thank you super chat
thank you thank you screw the tournament let's go watch the
event of cake that you the super chat that you think the
worst part is that i didn't have a chance to look at cake
before i went to play yeah we're we're basically out of the
tournament if we lose one if we lose um to any teams today
so maybe yeah there's a lot of strong teams still left
including this one so um i mean judging by the ranks like
This team seems really strong.
Looking at ranks-wise, that's why I'm like...
Oh!
Yeah, the pressure.
And they have two coaches.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh, my gosh.
I got this.
I'm gonna try my best to lock in.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
I'm just a bundle of nerves in general.
Okay.
Calm down.
Oh, calm down.
I thought we'd be ready.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Everyone's here, right?
I'm here.
I'm all here.
Yeah, I'm here.
Okay.
Oh, I...
I'll go here.
In the worst case, we can pause.
We can pause anyway, I think.
I gotta put on socks.
Hold on.
That's why we didn't win against Sarah.
I have socks on.
Oh my gosh.
The sock.
Gotta wear the good stuff, you know.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
all right also today actually i had a little morning scare
um dad woke me up um with like a cry like he was getting
murdered and i was like freaking the fuck out i actually had
to take him to the like emergency this morning because i was
like i don't know what the fuck is going on um but i found
him basically he uh i bought like this like little blank
this blanket that holes in it and i didn't realize he like
got under it he got into it and he got his foot got stuck in
the hole he couldn't get out of the hole and he was like and
i woke up and i was just like and he was like and i heard
like like it was so scary it was like the scariest cry i've
ever heard i've never heard of make that sound before and
he's like like freaking the fuck out i was like what
happened like he literally woke me up and um and then like
he got really like basically he was like super trim like
traumatized after i got him out of the blanket um and but
all he wanted to do was just hide in like like burrow under
like the blankets and stuff like under not the whole blanket
but like the his usual blankets and um and i was freaking
out because he was like i tried to like check his like every
like check his body and everything but he was like shaking
and he was just like what the fuck like i i want to be in my
blanket and he was calling into his like his like kennel and
everything too and i took him to the vet and he was like oh
he seems to be fine right now but they're like he might have
dislocated like a finger on his back leg and then he like
relocated it back like he doesn't know you might have pulled
a muscle he could have pulled a muscle he could have
dislocated a finger or something um and just put it back but
he's like he seems fine right now yeah so they're like oh he
seems fine right now but any it could have been anything um
no it's my dog my dog i call him dad uh because his full
name is doki amber doge um and then so it's really confusing
to call him doki as well so that's it's like um it's my dog
um and see what they burn and then um and i was freaking out
like i was i literally like took him to emergency vet i came
back just in time for screams and then i did and i went like
I went straight to here so I'm like a little tired I woke up
super early because uh I had to take him to the vet uh and
then the vet was just like he seems fine but he's just going
through some I guess he's just traumatized right now so I
was just like oh thank god okay he's just traumatized at
least you know that's the least it's so pretty bad like he's
traumatized from the incident um so but at least like it's
not it's not like anything bad i don't know if these guys
play dive or not yeah just i thought you would like sprain
his ankle or some yeah i don't think it's a little trauma
because he just wants to like he just wants to hide under he
just wants to like hide under his uh like blanket right now
he's just like huddled furled under his blanket he doesn't
want to be out of it we can say play we can play venom at
least physically he's okay so like that's why i'm like all
over the place at the moment but just a shy little guy well
not shy just to try like just a guy with trauma something
i've never heard that cry before i was it actually like it
traumatized me when i heard the cry yeah i think we should
phoenix yeah it's bucky phoenix Bucky Fiend, Bucky Fiend.
Magidot?
Yeah, Mac.
I do think, I don't know if it's Bucky Fiend.
I feel like the Wolf Phoenix is infinitely better
personally.
They're gonna play Hulk though.
Bucky's infinitely better into that, no?
Yeah.
You just burn the guy.
Did I play Rocket?
Uh, Cloak.
Yeah, it's probably Rocket.
Not straight, don't you think?
Uh, you can go Luna if you want, or Cloak.
Oh, okay.
Uh.
Which is best.
Let's see the map.
This map, I think.
Rocket is even best, actually.
Yeah, I think Rocket is not bad.
I think Rocket in general is always good.
Like, Rocket Inverse is like meta.
Kind of when the other three supports are bad, then...
So you're the almighty feats, eh?
Not really a different choice you can have.
I guess you could try Deadpool or Jeff.
I'd cat TP bomb.
They might try.
Yeah, they will definitely try that.
Right.
Jump hack right here.
I need jumpers too.
Can you leave the thing?
Yeah.
Do you have jumpers?
I have.
You can take it away.
Okay, let me see.
No TP.
They're playing...
Bullcwolf thing.
They're gonna be throwing the wolverine fight Phoenix right
on the right side okay do them on the right dog walk out the
hook guys look behind us behind us hooks okay care
Wolverines bottom right Wolverines bottom right we don't
have res the half spot next Wilboppa cut it walk forward
walk forward walk forward I've grabbed you I got you Phoenix
stop right wolf wolf wolf wolf one kill wolf wolf wolf wolf
two one yeah yeah i'm lucky i'm reloading reloading we
should have we should be right oh he got he got the rest he
got the rest come back come back kill the hole kill the hole
just live just kill him i kill him i kill him just kill him
just kill him i'm one i'm one i didn't have a dash i'm one i
need cap that's okay They're gonna die as well probably.
I can hold point, I can hold point.
I kind of want to try and clutch.
About to die.
I die anyways.
Go group up, go group up.
Get out, get out, get out.
Don't you, do guy?
They used it as well.
A lot of cards.
Complete up.
Just wait, just wait.
I'm not there yet.
They fall right side, Felix.
That'sSUI fall left side.
We'll rain on the right.
Wolverine's on the right.
They might push inside the room with Phoenix expected.
I think go right side, go right side, go not pretty much
inside.
yeah range right back close walk open three two one shoot
the ring they're gonna take off they're gonna take off we
walk walk walk walk walk walk walk i'm one i'm one i'm one
we can kill thing we can kill thing we can kill thing no
shit i'm grabbing thing half thing half i have no res i have
no res phoenix one phoenix one phoenix one live it live it
live it i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm i'm i'm
stacking on snake eggs i'm stacking on snake
wolf Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Loki won.
Phoenix won point.
Loki half.
We have rocket.
I should just TP.
Go back, go back, go back.
They TP'd.
I'm gripped.
I do have Riz, but I don't know you.
I should have TP'd.
We're here.
Can we play bottom left?
Can we walk bottom left?
We gotta touch.
We're gonna move.
They're gonna move us.
Anika.
We try.
This.
one walk all the way left we need to go soon can you walk it
okay okay or nothing big gold big gold in this one in this
one in this one nice behind us rock it on me he's gonna
maybe ult me i need care there we go okay let's chill what
do they have they have still have whole foot they still have
thing old there are a lot of ones we can't really keep
to shoot them get ready to shoot them from range okay just
i'm looking for my ult and then i want us to shoot their
backline in range okay so they're they're invisible far away
from us hold hold right side they're gonna push you inside
hold right okay yeah you hold right side they're all left
they're all left right now can we play coast can we play
coast play coast bring low hold left side i have to break my
uh i broke my room raise one holding i think she reads right
Break lamps, break lamps.
Look, Hulk!
I'm gonna match this.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool!
Nice!
Kill the Hulse!
Live it, live it, live it!
I match him.
I'm going up high.
I'm gonna get Wolf produk.
I'm gonna get Wolf over it.
Yeah, yeah.
Wolf on me.
Wolf on me!
He can't Wolf, Wolf.
He got me!
The Phoenix ran after me.
Come to me, Krupp!
I can't.
Wolf on me!
I'll shoot.
Think that.
I will TP.
Yeah, wait.
You have to die on.
We got two.
I'm dead.
No lamps.
They're down two.
Should have time for TP.
They have no lamps.
I'm going to take them out really fast.
I'm boosted.
I can't do anything about that though.
I can't play into wolf crook.
It's useless.
I swear I can't do anything.
It should be free though, but we can stay this, but we need
to just shoot them more, I think.
They shouldn't have that good resources.
All right.
what can i do against the phoenix he's been in a hard boat
chasing me everywhere yeah yeah you have to avoid them like
when you know he's flanking you just have to walk behind the
corner so he doesn't see you the next best thing you can do
the best thing you can do is just listen to the footsteps if
you're here you need to hide yeah i'm just trying to get on
i can't go anything as well all i want is a little peace
yeah just play this uh I guess we can play this again.
Let's see.
Did I try Emma?
Yeah, I try Emma.
Go Emma.
Emma's fine.
Be careful though.
Maybe you can grab the enemy wolf.
We just need to put more pressure on him.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Are we going to play?
Yeah, they're likely to do it by the way.
No, go main, go main, go main, go main.
Okay, okay.
No TP.
They're gonna vote for main.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fiend top left.
I wall myself.
Where's wall?
Wolf on top left.
He's thrown in.
He's gonna brawl.
They're gonna brawl.
I'm gonna brawl.
I can't.
I'm into dead.
No, just.
Oh, nice.
They used a lot.
He's heavy as well.
He's coop up.
I don't know.
Oh, I don't live.
He's chasing me.
Kill the hook maybe.
No, it's fine.
Just chill.
Just wait.
Rockets, launch it again.
There's a wolf in main.
We can wait, we can wait.
We can walk up together.
Let's wait.
I woke up three, two, one.
Swing out, guys.
They're all top left.
Just walk main, just walk main.
They can't hold it.
Just walk.
They're all there.
Walk main.
Can you grab the wolf?
I have two items.
I have this.
I was gonna die.
We think it died.
Thing one, thing one, thing one.
Still die.
I'm dead.
You can't live outside.
Live outside then.
I'm trying to live.
I'm off the map, I think.
He jumped off too, though.
Kind of crazy.
I can see if it's in the back.
I'm living.
Can I still win?
I'm one.
We should win.
I put a res out.
Nice.
You have no ease.
There's wolf on point.
The wolf.
Someone else should wolf, please.
I'm fine.
Thank you.
I'm here no way.
We need to develop on them.
We need to make a play now.
We need to walk.
Don't be so scared.
Just walk at once.
Just walk.
Kill them.
Kill the people off the point.
Hold one.
No more.
He's team aggro.
Can I?
Okay, okay, okay.
Just wait.
Play slow.
We have squirtles again.
Phoenix.
There were a lot of stuff.
I think five volts.
No.
let's hold up left a bit let's hold up left a bit don't give
it up for free phoenix coming here oh they got my they found
my runes oh i'm grabbed and i'm dead they don't yeah they
found my It's good old.
I might kill the idol.
The old one.
Leave the win.
Nice old.
Good point, point, point, point.
We can go touch.
Kill this guy.
I didn't mean.
It's kind of crazy that what stage grabs me.
Just wait.
We need to get Rocket.
They use nothing, guys.
They use nothing.
We should just play for Groot combo.
They're coming top left again.
Yeah, we need to get through without Groot combo.
So use everything onto it.
Play on me.
So top left guys.
We have to go here.
Okay.
Not set up.
You can flip there, main.
Wolves left side right now.
No shot.
They're all the way.
I'm going there, right?
I'm going main.
Phoenix half, maybe.
Phoenix going in.
Phoenix walking up.
He's going to ult us.
Phoenix's holding up.
Phoenix's walking up.
He's gonna ult us.
He's gonna hit.
I'm 96.
I need to roll.
I'm dead here.
I'm dead.
Kill the backline.
Loki, Loki, Loki.
I'm dead.
He was dead.
He was one.
Nice.
We can win.
Oh, he didn't ult.
Fuck.
I got so low, dude.
I'm with you, Snake.
He's one.
No, I die.
Loki won.
I can't.
I'm just alone.
I'm dead.
One more fight.
I get rest, though.
We have better.
We can walk early.
Go top left, I think.
Go top left.
Just go with Rocket Hood, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, walk the breath then just go.
Yeah, full cooldown.
Maybe thing.
Wait everyone, wait everyone.
Just walk deep this time, okay?
They think they ulted me.
They still ulted me to kill me.
Yeah, they don't have them.
They don't know.
They're gonna have wolf.
Phoenix on top right.
Can we walk?
Don't see wolf yet.
You guys need to walk first.
There's a wolf.
He's down below.
I'm walking.
Grab the wolf.
I go.
Kill the wolf behind.
Hulk behind.
Turn Hulk, everybody.
Turn Hulk.
He missed one.
He's to left.
He's gonna die.
Oh, he's gonna die.
I've walked.
bro we almost have invas just live just live i'm trying to
there's a phoenix behind you there's a phoenix behind you
crook i mean as long as i can but i die crook i need to go
that dude first and i just carry and just kill everyone i
think i'm really frustrated i can't play into wolf it's
impossible i if i can't play the game like we don't have any
development on the map i need to be able to play either save
Venom or save Wolf save that pool one of the two things has
to happen need to be able to play
but yeah I mean this matchup should be good like we should
be able to drain the wolf HP it's fine let's play for that
pool yeah let's play for that pool oh it's convergence what
map we can go central I don't know what to do I'm getting
chased by the phoenix everywhere i'm just like i i run away
but like he follows me everywhere i guess we don't bankrupt
and when i'm with crook he just shoots me through him he
just still shoots me yeah no there's so it's best of three
so we have a chance to turn this around yeah we can go
clinta or central park If you want to play Broly, it should
be killing him.
No, I use my dash.
I use my dash to avoid the Phoenix, but he just, he has a
dash too.
He dashes in to me.
And then the thing is, like, I might, I have to wait.
I can't do anything else after that.
Yeah, I literally, every time I've used a dash for it.
Yeah.
No, I did.
They just said just hide.
and I'm like I'm hiding but she's still chasing me and
they're like just listen to her footsteps so you know when
she's coming and I'm like okay lose every time yeah and then
like literally I asked in the advice was like just live like
just just hide and I'm like oh I think that's a good idea
yeah it's just hard to outrun her I mean I'll try my best
I'll just I'll save two of my dashes blocking Buckyall is so
dumb when you're like on top of it I did I was using walls
to like dash too he can't block it though but he's just he
can aim this guy is like one of the their pros and he just
shoots me like it's not like right where like you can still
work behind you know the non-pros they're playing this is a
pro player it's just really frustrating yeah no they nerfed
the wall running they nerfed it so your wall run really slow
now yeah
he's a dps he's one of the dps pros so it's like really hard
no they want me on rocket I don't think I don't like Luna is
like really bad right now
they said they want rocket for this so I'm just like I'm
trying I feel bad because I'm getting hard targeted hard
targeted but the phoenix i can't outrun her
oh what about playing punisher if they're playing like
thinghulk at least until they get a mag go starlots starlots
is infinitely better into that just shoot them on range they
can never you can't try my best so at least you drain hp
just need to go i don't tell them they're just like hide
better you just got i just gotta be more aware of the
phoenix and i'll say i'll say two of my dashes yeah i feel
like money would it's fine with i guess i'll just save two
of my dashes
yeah at least at least until then miss go at least until
they swap into mag and then we could swap it up again we
could save if we want yeah but i i do think we just saved
that pool and i just played the game if i played that pool
last game we actually just win i don't even doubt it the
hero just does because they're already brawling with other
people they're already brawling and um i was trying to
follow crook everywhere but like he also um the moment he
goes like when the phoenix sees crook he goes invisible so
then the phoenix just swapped targets to me because that's
what happened when i was like playing with him he like went
invisible because he had the regen and then the phoenix just
went for me and then i was just like oh yeah what we had in
this game with loki and mantis so it's like it's so hard for
me because like i guess they won't ban that pool then then
you can say i just guys i guess i just gotta be aware of
where the phoenix is but it's so stressful to be aware i
think it's the best choice it's so stressful to be aware
phoenix or wolf what do you want to ban guys we should ban
wolf against the wolf i'll burn it yeah especially if
they're playing hulk thing too because he's just gonna get
thrown around half the time you don't have to worry about it
i mean the fact is they had everything they had all the team
ups for the wolf so he was just serve admin and i play good
so i can't stop him someone else has to stop him it's like
really annoying i better not have win the game fruits that's
a okay safe i guess just take all supports now or what do
you do who am i gonna banish from this match i guess still
do mantis man yeah i need a mantis man yeah mantis wolf
mantis wolf just because i have to hide my roses better
because they keep finding all my roses it's so frustrating i
was like i'll put it here and then they're like found found
it.
Um, here?
I don't know where to put my reses.
They found every single res I put.
Because they're always trying to fling.
The thing is, if I put too far away, I would put too far
away.
That's when we can finish.
Could be Angela.
Then like, then they won't get the res.
Pick me!
Please!
Invisban, pretty good.
Yeah, Invisban's fine.
Probably.
I mean, now we get a good matchup, I think.
Save.
What do we save here?
I think...
Luna or Rocket or Invis?
I think Invis.
I think Invis, yeah, I think Invis.
I like the Invisban a lot.
I mean, normally we can't ban it, they just saved Koot
first, so I guess we just took it for that.
Normally it's harder to ban it.
It's alright.
You'll need a top notch team to win this way.
Okay, I mean, that's fine.
Koot ban is kind of okay.
I wanted to play Deadpool anyway.
W.
I think we just played Phoenix Star, and I don't think they
can stop it.
And the question is, what does Doki play?
Do we go Luna Rocket or Invis Rocket?
Invis Rocket should be better, to be honest.
The only issue is that the Phoenix just is chasing me
everywhere.
And when I'm like, he like uses his dash to dash to me.
We can also play Invis Luna.
But then I have to like frontline into like it's not good
because they're going to have Groot.
So be aware they're going to have Groot.
We can go Luna Invis, but then we should keep you behind
them.
I'll do that.
It's possible.
Actually, I'll go to UTP.
TP?
The TP from before?
Yeah.
I got...
I can bubble it.
They're gonna maybe stun it.
Be careful.
The Phoenix's song that goes through the cosmos.
I'm impressed you can hear it.
It would sound sick with a beat under it.
I think I could sample it.
Let's trade.
The Phoenix is all about creation.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
all you need to do is capture the mission area got it that's
easy they have adam triple with adam probably oh loki yeah
i'm doing it now hulk and um hulk and grude with loki
they've been ready for slam yeah i go behind i can hit three
two one No lamps, wait the lamps, wait the lamps, wait the
lamps.
No one died on.
We need to shoot the Hulk, guys.
Hulk one, don't make them yet.
I don't have Paul, I didn't have Paul.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
I'm nice.
I'm shooting three.
I'm on HP.
Good half.
Can we lift?
I can't.
Need to get out, need to get out.
I have upgrades.
Just wait.
Can you give me flake crook?
I don't give up so easily.
Oh, what the fuck?
From behind.
I'll go around them.
I'll try at least.
Need to go top left.
I have upgrades soon.
We can maybe, can you slam backline and we kill Groot here?
Ready?
Everyone?
3, 2, 1.
Groot, 2, 1.
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot.
They have no runes.
Okay, go back.
Go back.
Take a decent cast Yeah, it's like right now Good Good good
good Good good I'm still shooting group We're all one I'm
going to pull the back No soul Come on They're still
suffering You're me Who's first Info Who's defensive Oh
defensive It's offensive It's all." It's good It's good
You're dead probably Oh You guys live Actually winnable
Actually winnable I can look I can Yeah I put Chat 10 Can
you damage me I'm not like this I don't know It's too late
Too late Oh, I got XO.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam has self-pres.
Help Doki, help Doki.
Group one, group one, group one.
I got Luna.
Adam, one, one.
Phoenix one.
Hold flow, hold flow.
Phoenix, uh, nice.
I can try to get it.
No, we're good.
Sorry.
Snake, let's try to combo.
Cool, give me Flake.
You need this game.
Yeah, I just didn't know you were doing it until I was
already out.
I got him, I got him.
Swipe check them.
Do we kill him?
One, one, one, one, one.
No lamp.
We can hit after.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, Snakes.
Wait.
Let them up.
They go right side.
Cloak, no fade.
I'm matching it.
I'm going top.
I hit them.
They're all behind me.
I need help.
All one, all one, all one.
I'm good.
I'm dead.
They can clap.
I got a cap card.
How did he lift that?
They've aided it.
Go next.
I guess, yeah.
Yeah, they're on slowdown.
They're gonna have Drew Phoenix again.
Yeah, play slow.
Copy.
Can go behind them.
I go top left.
He killed.
I'm gonna slam him.
Three.
one got him grasped can can can't go more i got altered i'm
dead i mean they just knew me i'm flipping i'm flipping i'm
running away combo this fight nothing behind nothing behind
yeah peek me peek me uh they're shooting me i'm on clock
right now dead cap and point Jump!
Live it, live it, live it, live it, live it, live it, live
it.
Hit after, hit after.
It's fine to give cap.
Shoot the crude, okay?
Ready?
I got him.
Two, one.
Crude, Crude, Crude, Crude, Crude, Crude, Crude.
Look for all.
Look for all sake.
I'll keep guys.
I'm tired.
Add him, add him, add him, add him, add him.
No more.
Live it, live it, live it, live it, live it.
We need main feed.
Any help?
I feel like we need to support all that now.
It's livable, it's livable.
We hit after, ready?
yeah i thought we just killed on this now just went into the
diamond backline backline no loki one already one shooting
loki i'm dead they're still down i get all this born again
okay okay they're gonna rest made that agree i think the
group's living too much yeah i'm breaking the group wall can
kill the group can kill the group look at all i'm gonna
sleep three two one shooting good i'm one good one good one
dead no more support right now i need help oh the phoenix is
up top look behind lift please lift please everyone just
focus on the ring just focus on the ring just focus on the
ring don't you want to see me again we're doing this okay we
force we force we force can you live i live i live i live
just focus on the ring just Come back, come back, come back.
He's gonna push you, he's gonna push you.
Just lift.
I hit from behind, ready?
Three, two, one.
Come on, Adam.
No lab.
Can we get out?
Can we live?
Yep.
Oh, I'm running away.
I have ult in two.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
I hit back lane.
I ult them.
Oh, I'm gonna die as well.
Adam 1.
Adam 1, Adam 1.
Dead.
Try to live, try to live.
I can go on Loki.
Yeah, yeah, no TP.
He's one, he's one.
Shooting, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I pulled him back.
Oh, he didn't die.
I have water after this.
Just chill, just chill.
I'll hold it.
Don't die for anything.
Yeah.
They probably have good art again.
Probably close, yeah.
They care.
He's doing that right in the open.
I don't know what's yet.
I will continue.
Live it, live it, live it, live it.
I have touch, I have touch for a bit.
i demak all right i need help i need to work soon don't know
i'm on fien fien fien fien fien no i'm one i'm on i'm dead i
killed loki fien low-key i'll fight for my family until the
end phoenix phoenix phoenix phoenix phoenix i can't and i'm
led to death oh we don't have ppi there oh we should maybe
ban phoenix instead that's too much as well the current
score is one two We need a better hit on the backline, guys.
Need to wait out the dome.
And we need more pressure on the Groot.
I guess go Wolf.
I'm saying it.
Just go Wolf, Phoenix.
I feel like I don't know where to position.
I don't know where to position, guys.
Because it's like everyone's so split up.
Yeah, I think Mac.
Just get Mac and just go Phoenix, Wolf.
I think Emma actually.
Because they're going to crew now.
I'll just go wolf.
It's fine.
I think mag is essential for invas and...
No, they don't have invas.
Just go wolf and just grab them.
They can't do anything about it.
It's too OP.
The hero is so good.
Wait, ammo or magneto?
Ida is fine.
I think mag is honestly better.
But if you feel like emma is easier than throw emma.
You like they have to TP back though.
I got it.
Be careful.
We can flake the wolf as well.
should be fine to flake wolf i'm gonna stack with you guys
i'm just gonna play slow every cycle that i get we can try
to one-shot root do i just follow you around crew
positioning actually crew give me flake i need to flank i
think here you just need to play around this position with
me i'm gonna play around point two and i'll walk to you
after the man they start pushing all right they play tank
yeah they're gonna find the primary support right now yep
shouldn't focus them too much oh i'm gonna go for grew here
yeah i got him turn turn turn turn turn just chill just
chill don't think he can get rest they're gonna have a
support out very soon like don't feed don't feed don't feed
i'm always they probably have to guide it we need to walk
inside and give ticks okay when they support ult do want to
try to kill early can we can we push here with my old hold
on i'm gonna grab hook here oh i what the i go in three two
one i can't bubble you need one you're gonna stay i don't
mind just hide hide hide hide hide it hide it can you oh i
tried to i was trying to save crook you need to tp you need
to tp you need to tp Doug, we can still play with you.
Wait a second.
Hide, hide, hide.
You do zero damage.
Just wait.
I go in.
Two, one.
Yeah, but you need to ult before that.
I was dying to Moon Knight.
Take, take, take, take, take, take.
Take the P. Take the P. Take it, take it, take it, take it,
take it.
That's okay.
Go, wait.
Go next fight, next fight, next fight.
I, oh, okay.
I couldn't make it, too.
I see you.
I should have this whole thing down.
you want me to sir the Groot is just waiting they know they
know I think yeah they're looking for you watch out yeah you
don't know they don't know now they don't know Phoenix one I
can't kill him okay and he kills me no he breaks big wall
Phoenix is playing for all got him I got
I got touch guys.
I can hold it.
I'm touching it here.
Walk forward, walk forward.
Can I group moonlight?
Can I not just die?
Uh oh.
I ee us, I ee us, I ee us.
I ee us.
I'm bad.
Why are you aiming at?
No, it's okay.
Loki won, Loki won, Loki won though.
I don't give up so easily.
I can kill.
Can you roll deep in this world?
I died there, but I'm coming back now.
I died in the group moonlight all.
I don't I don't think I could touch I messed up We should
have given in this Oh, I missed all I'm dead here
We gave him cloak all early too.
We just kept feeding into him They're sitting in the bubble
I feel bad
Yeah, we're out of the tournament I feel bad.
I just felt, I definitely felt heavily targeted.
It happens.
It's fine.
Yeah, I mean, we're out, but we can...
I don't know if you can still make it out.
No, it's...
No, no, no.
Two games you don't...
Yeah, two games you don't go to finals.
Do we lose two?
I see.
Are you sure?
yeah yeah it's confirmed there's no way
what wait it's first of three no no he's just rolling us i
see she's just rolling i was like i think like people forgot
that i needed to be microd because i said oh can you guys
tell me once at all and then i just been waiting i don't
think we play all the other games then you want to call it
or what yeah i don't think there's i mean yeah yeah yeah i
mean do we i don't know if we should no i think we should i
think we should play them i kind of don't to be honest but i
don't either i don't think it's worth i get i get groups
points we just leave i don't know because we have two our
weights in between again it's gonna be same as yesterday
No, it's okay.
GG's guys.
If you guys want to call it, I'm cool with that.
I think it's top 10 teams.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure like...
No, no.
They said if you have a seven to one record, they reiterate
Sarah Times.
If you lost twice, you don't proceed to fine around.
We can't get top 10 with two losses anyway.
It's not possible with these many teams.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
I mean, it's fun with me too.
i'll talk to my mother because my father died a year ago
like exactly on today so i'll see and i played this
tournament bro it's kind of crazy but uh i'm i'm sorry if i
was kind of down today too i have a lot of going on right
now that no i see i'm sorry i'd really tried i really tried
my best the games were fun though like i still had a good
time okay okay i had fun playing with all of Yeah.
That's important.
If you want Doki, I can play ranked later.
If I after I talk to my mafia, so you don't have to like end
stream now or whatever.
Oh, yeah, sure.
Maybe if you want.
I don't mind.
I'm down.
GG's guys.
GG's, GG's, GG's, GG's.
GG's, GG's, GG's.
Sorry, Snake is too.
No, you're fine.
That was, that was a good experience.
Like I actually learned a lot.
I'm going to rate you though.
Okay.
okay i i appreciate your tips trust me actually it made me
think about the game differently pause i mean yeah that's
that's the point it's fine it's fine it's kind of have to
like work hard right and then you do your best all right
yeah i see you guys around ggs
i feel bad i feel really bad i i like held my alt for so
long too because I was waiting for the cause for it and then
like the one time I got called to ult I I didn't finish
listening to Kropea use it defensively and I already ulted
it I was like oh I'm sorry I felt so bad and then um and
then yeah and I just was waiting for um i was waiting to be
microed but i felt like um i think everyone was like so
chaotic yeah everyone was so chaotic so i just i i didn't
think for myself and stuff too um well yeah but when i was
rocket too when i was on rocket um i was like holding it as
well and yeah
and yeah and then like I was holding on to it and because I
was waiting to like for the call and I felt like oh I could
have built my alt like three times here
yeah yeah I feel I just feel bad because I felt like I was
sort of dragging my team back there because I as because i
also got picked i was getting picked several times because i
was just like
no we had really bad matchup rng in general yeah we had like
two good teams and then like tara's team is literally just
literally just walk i mean his team is the best but like i'm
like bro give us the freebie teams yo you're the best team
this these teams are nothing to you give us the freebies
yeah it isn't lucky i know like i did learn a lot but i do
feel bad because for them the money means a lot to them too
so like they could if they like you know um by picking me
it's sort of like did set them back a bit um because i was
like the little baby on the team and i felt really bad
because like you know for them the money means more to them
um and i was just like oh i wish i wish i was a better
player type deal yeah um but i did i did I just felt like
they definitely, they definitely, the enemy team, uh, the
enemy team definitely hard focused on me because they knew I
was the weakest because like, I felt like I was fucking
being chased from Nania.
Like I've never felt like when we do, we're doing scrims and
stuff.
I was, it was not, I was not getting chased as hard as, as
that, yeah.
another tournament i do have another turn i i do have to
show up tomorrow though i do yeah i i do have to show up
tomorrow for like the show match i most likely i'll be
streaming that on twitch though because it's just a show
match and then i go back to rank yeah no it's for the j3
tournament um i'm in the show match for it okay i'm since i
don't have to try anymore i can put this back to window mode
i Like, you know, I do feel fucking bad, you know?
Because, like, Croak was obviously very mad.
Like, he instantly left.
And I was like, oh.
I'm just like, oh, he left instantly.
Oh.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's because, like, I...
I did get picked a lot.
So that's why I was just like, I felt like, you know, he
would have had an easier time.
And my positioning was, like, you know...
Yeah.
especially like the last fight when it was like me and him
and then the like i couldn't get back to him in time we're
doing right now i do um i think for me i because i don't
want to i don't know i just feel bad letting people down you
know i feel i feel really bad uh letting people down um and
i feel like oh man because for me like obviously uh the
money means a lot more to them and i uh i just felt really
bad because i was like oh if i played if i was a better
player we could have beat this team yeah but i definitely uh
i definitely i think like for these tournaments like it's my
i know j3 said he's gonna host another community clash but
i'm definitely not gonna join the next community clash
because i think unless he like unless i get into like the
captain slot for it because um the captain teams are a lot
easier um like not easier but they get in automatically but
like i will i feel like the teams that are in the cap the
ones that get in without having to go through the qualifiers
the teams that got in while having to go through the
qualifiers are a lot easier than um they're not like i'm not
gonna they're not bad but like some of the teams and the
qualifiers are harder than the um some of the teams and the
qualifiers are harder than the ones that got in
automatically i will say that i feel like i feel like it's i
feel like that because like the some of the teams that got
in aren't like um uh like the teams that aren't
automatically in they're like the top like you know the
current lan the current lan winners and stuff like you know
na winners or like eu winners and stuff that are in
qualifiers from what i've and i know like um because i've
seen two because there's four teams that get in
automatically and i've seen two for it.
And I know that, like, I know I know, like, five other teams
in the qualifiers that are stronger than the two content
creator teams.
Yeah.
So it's day.
So qualifiers was definitely very, very hard.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I didn't help that I had to fucking rush to the vet.
But I will take account of it.
I definitely was the weakest link there.
I definitely was the weakest link.
I mean, for sure, I...
Um...
I mean, like, the next time, if I do another...
If I do another...
If it was another similar tournament like this, I won't
participate unless I'm, like, automatically in...
Like, automatically in the finals!
because then like i don't because then i don't have to
disappoint anyone i don't have to disappoint anyone we're
automatically in anyway gonna be stronger i don't know just
because that you can first the battle starts in five four
three two yeah i do that that I didn't but like I did die a
lot of times when I shouldn't have died like when the
Phoenix was chasing me like if I was a better player I guess
I would have known where they were gonna fucking where she
was gonna fucking prepare cuz you're like just listen to
footsteps I was like oh my god I I do not play enough to
know what the fuck how to do that like so casually you know
just listen to it on footsteps I'm like man I wish I play
enough to be able to do that to be able to just listen to it
on footsteps and then predict the fucking future how the
fuck did the Groot live yeah yeah but they said it's so
casually it's like they like obviously cuz they're better
players like yeah it's like Like what you do?
And I'm just like, oh, listen to no push.
Oh we have a story for CG's.
Man I wish we have like a character that can, I don't know.
The a motherfucking destroyer was, at least I already went
through my, I'm gonna do the thing that I learned.
Aggressively forward!
Alright, well, we're dead.
I did my best.
Alright.
It was fun.
I did do the thing now.
I was tired.
I aggressively ulted forward.
No Invis.
Oh, that they killed.
They killed Invis.
Oh my god, let me through.
Can we, like, at least kill Groot?
Please, he is what?
Oh my, at least we finally did it.
Raid boss down.
What the?
Oh, I should have pulled him back.
He, like, surprised me.
Throw in all.
Watch the door roll.
Okay, I will say I definitely should have pulled him.
She might be top left now.
Yeah, she's over there.
She's out.
Yeah, I will, I think our team did not have enough time to
build chemistry.
We're definitely, like, chemistry over there.
wise definitely could have been better like you can have
literally the best players but if there's no chemistry like
you know we could have i don't know you know it would be
cool if we have a clone out right now look all right now yep
there we go yep that's fine i'll have to look up i'm getting
fucking beat up but that's fine i got tb back oh i could
have killed it
oh i got it i'm not gonna place the on my way for supports
no we had a warm-up scrim yeah no we did we had a warm-up
scrim but our warm-up scrim is was against like fucking
Tara's team.
I don't know.
I was just...
Like, playing against, like, the fucking raid boss.
Actual, like, Kobe Bryant.
Well, this is where we die.
Playing against LeBron James and Kobe Bryant.
He's back from the dead.
Every stream.
Every warm-up stream you play.
Why get off Invis?
Invis is literally the strongest on torch i don't know but
why didn't you pick fucking anything else then go get off
support let me go support i don't know i'll play it yeah i
feel like i'm doing it after all wonders on dps but what
whatever sub everything will kill i don't know if he knows
this but i mean i'll go fine i'll go look i don't think he
knows this but like no matter every support through moon
night grew up what the fuck does he mean can we get off in
this you're gonna die every support gonna die I mean I don't
play Loki like wait I rather play Loki I like Loki we have
some guy on our men's dorm but I'm the problem bro jeff
lives it yeah what does he do when he's like in the grudel
yep let me play loki and farm gives them fucking oh yeah
forgot we have literally sing the token that supports right
now it's fine like with them let them cook just let them
cook i guess like why bro look at this thing look at the
thing look and what if he's blue
that's crazy oh i guess i'll die here i'm swapping off loki
i'm gonna go rocket this gg support dip bro this guy is
fucking stupid actually stupid he's like he's like get off
in this group us gonna kill you what you know what happened
close all that too you know what fucking happens oh man like
bro we have a thing and he's like gg support this man's
actually dumb like look at him what is he doing oh man what
do we do What do we?
Wow, he's so lucky that I fucking was healing it too I'm
surprised that they lived through that actually I think they
fucked it up The fact that they lived through that was
fucking crazy Let's bitch him more play.
Thank God I fucking healed through it as well
No, it's because I was also like shooting my heal or I
didn't get caught in that Yeah, Groot ult too.
Have I grew?
No, if I didn't heal through it, they would have died.
They literally would have died there.
What am I gonna do?
I'm gonna chuck this in here.
Oh.
Nice.
So Groot dead.
Four.
Hell yeah.
Moon on point.
Super free kill.
But I did try to save his life.
life i try to save his life don't worry he gets res'd see
he's back i have ult for their loki copy
whoa i'm leaving right right side right side right side uh
yeah because he was out of the him is all we can't force an
all you know who i i know who i'm better than these players
at least.
Let's go.
At least I...
At least I know that.
Whoa.
Hey, hey, hello?
Hey, hello?
They're lucky like right here.
Alright.
I'm fine with that.
Wow, man, I wish I could, I did that to the Phoenix and you
know what she does?
He just kills me.
You know, that's unfortunate.
Try to do that for...
Yeah.
TP, TP if you die, TP.
Kill group, kill group, kill group.
Kill the supports.
I'm on with you.
Good all, good all, good all.
Really big all.
You hit the girl.
All right, there you go.
Why is both DPS on me?
What the fuck?
Yeah, the Loki didn't get a single ult that whole world.
Hello, Doom Q.
We've returned.
We guard the galaxy, sure.
Why couldn't the Phoenix be like that, Thor?
I did that!
To where the Thor, for the Xenics, I die instantly I think I
did that and then I die like in one second I did that the
exact same maneuver I'll make it with your wild Bucky go on
name your price yikes I mean technically I ain't a raccoon
but something yeah I can grab
this yeah i love you oh yeah i'm just gonna play zombies oh
man zombie times yeah i've only left phoenix couldn't aim
like those guys
okay now i think it's also if i haven't played like hot
doing so is all right oh they have a hawk i can't trust
myself i feel like i'd be the first one
okay that's a little too many elves yeah that's a little
that's a little we got a little two half oops some magic
here we got a little two happy too too zesty here with those
odds he's literally one nice i vote for a low-key copy or
whatever they decide to use you're ready for action i feel
like myself again i didn't really lack i haven't played like
the higher yellow games in a very long time oh oh my god wow
look at that dodged to all those phoenixes, I guess.
Yeah, I'm pissed from nowhere.
Yeah.
It's funny.
You're definitely not going to see that.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I swear to...
What the...
You fucking freak!
Holy shit!
What the fuck was...
Bro, that's actually crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Big, big, big, big, big.
They have no heels, yo, they have no heels.
That's crazy that...
Oh my god, that freaking freak.
He could have maxed out than anything else.
Literally anything else.
And he still picked me.
Jesus Christ.
Actual cringes behavior.
No.
Bro, stop!
No block, no block, no block.
Let me shoot him, we shoot him, we shoot him.
I don't have to use this.
Oh, fucking I leave, I guess.
Big kill.
I'm on your, I'm on the same target as you.
I'm on the magic.
Oh my god, he actually gets, oh, he couldn't get the magic.
Doesn't matter.
Fuck you And you in particular I mean Sure Ghost Oh my god
bro You're not gonna stop his TP You're not gonna stop it I
mean okay Okay that's fine I was gonna say you're not gonna
fucking stop the TP I guess Nice Oh he's dead No, she- oh
shit, that fucker!
Nice.
I'm landing at the end.
You're ready.
Three, two, one.
I'm in it.
I'm chasing their Invis.
Loki dead.
I mean, we are.
What the fuck, you freaking freak!
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
Yes.
One.
Wait, he's actually is one.
Magic one, magic one, magic one.
Magic one, magic one.
i think i do have one i think oh i'm here please don't make
me fight just myself
bro the moment i reload you're dead just that oh my god
hey look i did learn from the tournament and there's one and
there's one look see guys i learned from the tournament holy
Give up, bro Fuck you black star!
Carried your fucking ass!
Joy has got that stupid GM ELO
Stupid ass fucking Pisslow, I guess
Oh my god No one knows You mag
Yeah, I get I like how we all think this guy is a fucking
dog shit I triple your peak hush Oh, man.
Oh, man
All right, let's see it
Bro yeah I think you got that reverse buddy I I think I
think you got that fucking reverse bro this is cheaper than
therapy it is what changed the 10 I don't fucking know
because people be like oh how's how's oh wait let me I'll
just change the title I'll treat it like twitch just be like
doom queuing now JK, we doom queue.
JK, it's...
JK is doom queue.
I mean, I mean, it's GG go next.
It was one tournament out of many.
Of course, I would feel bad, though.
Crook.
Crook instantly left the group chat.
Okay.
yeah he he's definitely not happy he yeah he like just left
the group chat
he did not with us i mean well i i have to be like so it's
like oh i don't like how you blair but i i have to take
accountability like i'm not gonna make excuses for myself
like i was the weakest link on that team and obviously like
you know as the support partner for crook I did I felt
really bad because I was always leaving him out to solo by
himself um and like you know I can't just be like oh it's
not my fault like oh um and stuff so I'm just taking
accountability for like because like it was I I like I said
I was the weakest link and the other teams knew i was the
weakest link and like hardcore targeted me um i well it's
just because like during that last two games it felt like if
i was alive definitely like uh i just didn't know how to
play for my life in that situation yeah i just i just don't
know and i was like trying to ask
But when I try to take their advice, it was still happening,
yeah.
So it's like, it feels like, oh, maybe I should have, like,
obviously it's, like, all in hindsight, too.
Yeah.
It's, like, all in hindsight, like, obviously, if I was a
better player, I would have known how to survive better.
But it was just very difficult because it was, like, they
hard-focused me, and I felt like, oh, how could I have
positioned?
myself better in a way where and I was also like very I felt
like a headless chicken at times because I was trying to be
like when do I own and stuff yeah
yeah it was also like that was also uh
I mean I did learn a lot like I was fucking roaming or like
I was literally dodging everything as I did learn a lot
though playing this uh and and Um, and it's like, it's like,
I wish I, I wish that I was a better player, because I did
feel, I mean, like, you know, they're very sad about it and
everything, um, because the money means a lot to them, so it
was just more so of like, like, I'm not trying to be like
making excuses, and I knew that I didn't make mistakes
there, since like, I lacked the knowledge, I lacked the
knowledge and the game sense.
and i i definitely relied on them a lot on how to play and i
think that also obviously interfered a lot as well um and
because like you know i held my alt a lot as well i held i
was holding my alts um and i was like i was like where do i
go like i kept being like where do i position myself i i
feel like everywhere i go i die
like I was just like oh man everywhere I go and like I
definitely yeah and and it's like I I felt like I just I
needed to be microed I needed to be right microed but
because the way I play in rank is so different um the way I
play in rank is so different than the way I play in screen
because when I try to play the way I play in rank in scrims,
I got like not told off, but they're like, don't stop doing
that.
They're like, stop doing, like, not stop, they're like, just
like, stop doing that.
You're alting wrong.
And I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
Like, this wasn't like streamed or anything, but like, it
was like the very first scrim, the very first two scrims I
did with them, they're like, you're alting wrong.
Like, you should not alt like this.
And I was like, oh, this is how I alting rank.
I'm sorry.
And they're like, if you're, because like, I alt to try Like
I saw my tanks though and I was just like, Oh, I'm going to
rip it.
I'm just going to rip it.
And then, um, and then they were like, yeah, no, you have to
alt like this.
And I'm like, okay, okay, I'll do that now.
But obviously it's not the same as like, they're like, if
you, if the tanks are dying, just save your alt because
that's their fault.
That's the, uh, that's the tanks fault.
It's not your fault that like you didn't save them.
It's a tanks fault for feeding They ended up dying and need
an alt to save them.
And I was just like, oh, okay.
And I was like, oh, and that's why I was like, I think I
need to be micro because I don't know when to properly alt
then because I felt like every time we didn't have a, we
didn't have a lot of game plan.
No, I, no, I'm considered a non-pro.
I was categorized as a non-pro.
So I...
and no i don't want to do another vod review bro guys i
don't want to do a vod review guys i'm not fucking going i'm
not going through pro play ptsd yeah it's it's done it's
done i don't need a vod review i play this as a side thing
no more please yeah i'm i'm Yeah, and it's like, I know what
I did wrong.
It's just my positioning.
I know what I did wrong.
My positioning was just very not like, like they could tell
my positioning is worse than everyone else.
So they hard focused me because I just didn't know where to
go.
Yeah.
So it's like, it's just unfortunate.
They just knew how to focus me just because like, I am the
weakest player.
I got Whisper.
Oh, is that Agu?
Well, Truss said he wants to play, so I don't know if he's
coming back, but sure.
Sure.
Oh, fuck.
Um.
I'm just reflecting.
Reflecting about it.
Dude.
I mean, like, I said before one of the main reasons why i
feel really sad is that um i saw that trust me was looking
for players like trust me and crook and then one of my
friends is actually next door neighbors with crook so i
asked him if he could like okay give me a good word for it
like if i could join crook's team and um like you know and
then i felt bad because like my friend who's like next door
with crook got me on the team like yeah like yeah in real
life yeah like they actually known each other's for like
since before like before like he became pro and I felt
really really bad too because of that um because like you
know my friend vouched for me and um yeah so and then you
know that's why I felt really bad that crook obviously is
like not happy about it and uh yeah i'm just waiting for the
yeah yeah no i saw the whispers guys i saw it yeah sure yeah
sure yeah i saw the whispers guys yeah
that's why it sucks a lot more for me because obviously the
reason why i was even on the team was because um
to be like to be on that team and then I felt like oh man he
could have got like obviously a different support I
mean it's not discouraging me from tournaments overall but I
think for these tournaments this one the fact that it's very
very heavily in favor of like people who Like, I'm way out
of my, what's it called?
I'm way out of my comfort zone.
Like, not comfort zone, because way out of my skill level.
Way out my depth.
Yeah, I'm way out my depth in it.
Just because, like, the teams are element, because the teams
we're first seeing are people who play rank every single
day.
They play rank every single day.
this guy wait is that did i join some bud someone's random i
i hope this is aga i swear to god if i oh okay i okay okay
cute and it's like i just joining some guys random yeah i
hope that's his alt account yeah yeah
so it's like yeah constant vodka we can and uh scrims every
day and rank every day yeah i just no i've had that happen
i've had random people add me like randomly invite me and
just and i had to just block them i just i just blocked them
so because if you block them they can't spam invite and i
don't i don't got time for that i don't have time for for
that i bro i just I just like playing Rivals.
Nah.
But I made lots of mistakes too.
Fuck Indy.
Yeah.
I just hope my friend doesn't get beat up.
I'll go warden.
I'm going to ward him right now.
I'm gonna warn my friend.
I'm like, hey, show up.
He's gonna, like, that's why he, like, fucking ended stream.
He's gonna go over and beat up my freeze.
I was like, don't open your door.
I mean, like, I'll be like, bro, don't open your door
tonight.
Better lock it.
him better live yeah bro it's too late why didn't you why
didn't you tell him sooner i think it's already too late i
think he's gone no it's not trusty it's crook he's my friend
who's next door neighbors of him yeah i should have told him
half an hour ago before he left the group chat in game well
i don't even think it's in game guys i i don't even think
it's in game guys it might already be too late he's gone now
all right let me i'll message my friend and be late
all right mutual friends he keeps changing his name so i'm
like oh my god i fucking forgot i have him my old old
discord account he's basically my our mutual friend is just
uh is so i used to play apex with before i was in corpo he
doesn't play apex anymore but he was the one that like he
taught us uh he taught my friend and i'm also destiny as
well um oh my god i'm trying to remember what server we
share no it's Not this one.
Bro, he has...
God damn it.
We have like...
I'm trying to remember what server it is.
Where is the server?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, where is he?
I need to message him and be like, Bro, you better lock your
door.
I fucked up.
You gotta lock your door tonight.
Bro, I fucked up.
You better lock your door tonight.
I hope he doesn't come over and get you.
There you go.
Bro, dead.
now and then
yeah like croak is like and then like croak croak is falling
is on his skirt and he's like i got him it's too late i got
him now
you'll need a top-notch team to win this what do you mean
you got crook is responding
oh wait we have zaza what the fuck is this okay title
whatever even when you can't see me i'll still make you
believe 30 seconds before you attack get ready Okay.
He's, oh, Warlord's like, my friend, his name is Warlord,
and he's like, what happened?
He's like, what happened?
I explained it, and then he did, he stopped typing.
Oh no, he's like, oh no.
I don't know.
I was like, oh, that's all just sort of happened.
And he's like, oh, no.
Bro, bro, you're good.
He actually, all he typed was, oh, no.
It's clear I'm still needed here.
Bro, no, he's good.
Oh, man.
Oh, apparently Kirk really wanted to win that tournament.
so he was like alright so apparently he was saying that yeah
he really really wanted to win this tournament we still have
we do still have Widow holy shit I am very surprised we
still have Widow I thought he would you know I thought like
he would swap after everything that has had that has
happened you know what fuck it I'll just do it I'll do this
thing I'm gonna do it
oh I didn't think he was gonna this is not a lot of healing
but like I don't think we're winning this I don't think I
don't think it's winnable so like I'm fine
Oh, goodbye, everybody.
Oh, shit.
We're here for goodbye.
I mean, we got Spidey and Widow.
Like, I think it's, like, literally the combo.
Oh, my God, he's dead.
Oh, my God, we're dead, too.
Why would you all say...
so far from us holy shit that's crazy that was from nanya
that was actually from fucking nanya
okay let's just kill these guys
yeah am i the only one that's okay that's bad
oh my god i tried to self here Oh, hey, it's not- he didn't
go 05.
You know, if I was any other healer, this could have been
more winnable.
Not gonna lie.
Most likely, I have a feeling.
Only because then, then we would have more heals.
Man, it would be cool if we broke it.
yeah there we go all right I am bro that's funny the widow
is spamming I need
I would mind the explode there's a mortal in there are you
serious wait what happened what the fuck happened
oh my
oh hey it's me and the widow we got don't worry we got this
okay now I try I don't know I'm just thinking like does the
widow really deserve you though at this point is it there's
some moments where I'm like I don't think our team deserves
anything what I didn't have I didn't have Snap
Time to switch things up including which side you're on
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
I am Loki goddess of mischief and the queen of Asgard
Can I state your ship?
sure
round two 30
seconds before you attack no i don't know i don't hear
anything i was thinking all spider people are connected to a
spider totem all right so i wonder if they're like oh at
least we're gone triple support maybe we'll have more heals
now Imagine if there was a cliff here.
Alright, I better see like at least one kill from this man.
Jesus, I'm okay.
I am not okay no more.
I am no longer okay.
Aw, he got out.
Bro, okay, look, we someone has, okay, okay, guys, um, why
did, are they just walking into us like that?
Like, who's letting them do this to us?
Not you.
What the fuck?
How is he?
Wait, how?
I'm fucking gonna kill this guy.
Is this me?
How are they just walking into us like this?
Oh my god.
Bro, okay, I swear to God.
I feel like if I'm the only one shooting.
Life energy brings me back.
Final score.
Zero.
There's another door to that room.
GG.
Bro, there's no.
There's no way I I feel like widow players would just would
have I thought widow players went extinct after that like
I am I am surprised that Widows still oh no, I have to avoid
this guy too widows like still are Existing after what
happened.
Yeah Like I'm surprised I would have just you know know go
into hiding until they're welcomed back into society i got
widow widow there you go yeah like at that point they have
no no it's over it's it's it's fucking over they have no
there's no pr left for them
they should have like actually never come out of hiding
after that day they should be banished exiled from society
oh yeah it's over it's doom q time
it's doom q hours now oh that last team we fought that team
actually knows how to play dive why don't we know how to
play dive like our team doesn't we try to play dive but we
don't know what to do we never know what to do
no they're not they're not uh no tarot's team is most likely
gonna win his team is fucking insane in general
but my team we just never could understand i we could never
understand dad it was just over for us
turn him around you guys want a little dance all right don't
worry i got you guys
which hero do
you think you want to be today
gonna vanish from this match
i'm disassociating
give me a sec i gotta disassociate
yeah the the doom queue disassociation
you'll need a top-notch team to win this one
all right
okay give me a sec oh all right what you gonna all right i
play lowkey
i'll have you now it is true
there's lowkey bird time i'm not very streaming i'm like
thinking like how long should i play i'll do like another
hour and then Get ready, prep for...
And then do zombies!
Also have a lot of work to do too, so I can do work stuff in
between.
Between the zombies.
Uh...
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, two, one!
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Hey, Galactica!
No, no, it's Galacta!
Daughter of Galacta!
You idiot!
all right lucky bird I won't say I played my best I won't
say that I I definitely could have done better a lot better
in some areas because I made a lot of mistakes there as a
player yeah all right Oh my god!
We can count on you!
There we go.
Bro, can they, like, push up or anything?
Come on.
Give me a real challenge.
And then I'm, like, famous last words.
Give me a real challenge!
And then we fucking lose this game.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I was...
Wait, I didn't think they would actually...
Oh no.
Wait a minute.
Not, that's not what I mean.
But not now.
I didn't mean it now.
whenever i didn't think they would actually do it all right
do you think they're fine over there because i don't think
so oh they're fine oh fuck oh no do your thing go do your
thing you have up what my god why didn't he up what that
was a fucking bro your reaction time is faster than me he
was literally like I need here I thought he was gonna
fucking up that because he was spamming his oh my god I'm
fucking like doing this like this okay why did you shield
him and not me.
Why did...
The not shield me!
Oh, what the...
I am supporting you.
Like, if any, you're supposed to...
What the fuck was that?
He literally went and shielded and fucked it.
Like, what is he trying to shield i'm so like what could he
be shielding
holy no man these games these games are crazy oh my what
that's actually crazy i am so confused
The fact that he didn't protect the one person, the one
person that ulted for us.
It's crazy.
This yellow, man.
I need to get myself out of here.
Oh, that's fine.
We're sorry.
My clones are so far back.
There's no way.
Oh, wait, wait.
That's right!
Get back here.
Get back in here.
Okay, that might be a little too- Ah, no.
He builds all this really fast.
He builds all this super fast.
I'm gonna say, I don't know if Deadpool all it was fine.
You're here forever.
Now, he- she ulted, but it was just that whenever I mean I
could do this like what's he gonna do looking oh never mind
that's what he's gonna do I was like I'm not really that
scared
okay what am I doing I can just be here what am I what am I
doing jumping I could just be on high ground like yeah I was
just like let my fucking try like event what the fuck people
people people people sorry i'm trying to i was trying to say
bro my clone should have been over there oh my god if i knew
they were gonna push that close that's a little oh stupid
not gonna lie i'm just gonna die on point like there's no
reason for me to stop That's just beatboxing No, our team
was so Oh, we have another portal Alright Hold it, don't TP
yet He says
Hold it, don't TP yet What?
what am I wait what where
did it go did the portal aided what you can do that what how
did it do that I was on the air when I all did that's crazy
I was actually in the air That's actually bullshit.
I like jumped in the air and altered myself there That's
crazy it showed up on my screen
Yeah, and I like I like had it on I can't believe it
actually travels through the stupid portal That's crazy
That's actually insane of that fucking that RNG for that to
happen I don't trust my invested to help me there.
Okay, we can heal each other and then, oh, I guess we
cannot.
Yes, we can.
That's actually crazy.
I still can't believe that happened to me.
That was the craziest fucking oh wait, they weren't pushing.
Alright, which is already
Yeah, poor dude.
Well, now that I know that...
I jumped up hoping that I would like click...
Because I've seen it apparently happen in pro play before.
That's why people were like, what the fuck?
Because it has happened in pro play.
Who is he shielding that from?
Where the fuck are the supports?
is there like any support like we're at the support since
the enemy team the current score is zero y'all did disappear
Melkor did you give us super chat thank you thank you that's
crazy that that can like I've seen it happen like I've like
seen a clip of that happen um yeah yeah I jumped up to avoid
it, avoid it, but somehow it still went through.
I fucking copied it.
Yeah, like I jumped up and then I went and clicked below me.
But somehow me being above the portal placed it in the
portal.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
That's fucking crazy.
Max Ranger, oh, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
Yeah, I know something.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Oh, yeah, I've done that before.
Alright.
Oh.
No, I know what they mean.
I do that sometimes, but not all the time.
Because I don't feel safe.
I never feel safe.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe I wasted that.
Oh, I should have saved it.
Oh, I should have saved Invan!
Oh, my mantis is fat.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Technically, I didn't waste Invan because there was no way
to save them, technically.
If you think about it.
Oh, we can do this!
Let's go!
Well, now we can't do anything.
Well, never mind.
Technically we can't do anything no more.
Oh, unless!
Oh.
Let me just chill here, I guess.
There you go.
Like, I don't know what their whole plan is.
I don't know what the Emma's plan is to try and fucking mind
control me.
But I ain't no Snow Bunny.
Alright.
This here?
Like, don't keep these.
All I'm saying is I'm the wrong target for this mind
controller.
You literally, like, went up to me.
I was just like, bro, what the fuck are you doing?
Not me.
Wrong person.
Not the right demographic.
I should save him.
Nah, he's fine.
Oh,
that's awkward for me.
Oh, nice.
He's aiming for the mantis.
That's good.
Okay, I don't know what his plan is.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
win this let's go
there we go i told you it's still winnable no longer no
longer no it's still winnable oh that's awkward for him all
right so the only issue is that they do have buckio and they
do have this in that cubby hook oh and he missed it's okay
he didn't hit my clone so he can't Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god, they kneeled.
Oh, see, it's winnable.
It's so winnable.
It's always winnable.
It's so over.
We're so back.
Oh, I don't know why I put that there.
It's just for aesthetic, I guess.
I was like, hmm.
wanted that clone in there.
Like a little buddy.
My new best friend.
Myself.
Fuck, I don't trust.
I need heals.
I have another ulti soon.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, everybody.
I don't even think this is a winnable fight.
We lost three.
Nope, we lost four.
Wait, I can't.
can't count it was actually three that's all right you don't
watch me for my math i think if i copy cloak it'd be better
right i need to oh
oh don't wait we'll have double
Again!
Round two!
There you go, round two, round two!
There's no way.
What's your push?
Okay, we had three people pushing, we actually would have
made it.
Okay, that's...
Oh, Daisy jumped up!
You're so stupid!
Three, two, two!
You're seriously jumped up in this hug.
Nice.
What a throw.
Easy.
Just like that.
It's just that easy.
Wait, what was it?
Oh, I've done that before.
I already know how to do it.
I mean, I'm going to be up front.
Valid.
Oh, like, basically what he's saying is, like, if I know how
to, like, just Invisalt into, like, not be, like, just be
far away and just Invisalt like that.
And I was like, yeah, I know.
I just don't care.
It's rank.
I'm just...
I'm just playing the play.
Also, especially in this Elo.
I normally don't get punished.
Yeah, it's a Doom Q for a reason.
Exactly.
Who
am I gonna banish from this match?
Exactly.
Arnie is the Bathrow Bear back, guys.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Alright, I'm back.
Okay, Jeff.
What the fuck are these, like, Elo-Terrorist lobbies?
I guess because I am an Elo-Terrorist as well.
Alright.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Actually, no.
This might be pretty bad.
Animal Crossing.
Let's go.
Uh, Juge, thank you for the super chat.
Uh, Juge, uh, Burr, uh, Bayet, W, Lacron, Alan, thank you
for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I mean, we're all euloteric in this lobby.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Three, two, one.
It's alright, they don't need my heals.
Oh my god.
I wonder I has the new the newest one has to be DPS like she
literally has a fucking shotgun what's she gonna do like
shotgun the heels the heels are my shotgun pellets to shoot
someone to
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure like um I fucking knew it I
had a feeling Oh yeah, nice.
Our heal.
Oh.
It's okay.
Everyone is still somehow alive.
Which is always nice when they somehow are still living.
You know what?
Fuck.
You're up.
This is what I learned.
Oh, wait.
Okay, I did not expect that to.
Okay.
Um, Jeff, I am.
Jeff, what about...
Jeff, no.
Why did you...
Jeff no why didn't Jeff why did you bring me back what holy
fuck what the fuck I why did you why did you bring me closer
to closer to my team Jeff why would you bring me here how
did you spit me into the other all Jeff
That's fucked up, bro!
Bro, I don't, yeah, no, he fucking out of that.
Okay, that's over.
Oh, there's no way that, that thing was so fucking deep.
Oh, I got it on the map.
taking the portal but where I have one res oh well that is
to that we well I had one res only one yeah
could play actually wait they don't have wait I could play
oh no I was gonna say, I could play Cloak, but I think
knowing me, I just fucking slam into a penny mine.
Knowing me, that seems like something that's gonna happen to
me.
Oh, you should, you can take him.
You can take him.
You're Deadpool.
You're the better Deadpool.
You're so much stronger.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
We kill him.
He's literally with our ults.
Okay, I guess we cannot kill him.
Alright, never mind.
Unfortunately.
It's alright.
Everything is fine.
Okay, why do we always double support us though?
But...
Like, I don't fuck with that.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm spitting my orbs
out.
As fast as I can.
Alright, maybe we might have to swap, we might have to swap
support, maybe Rocket ain't working.
Well, I mean, the other, Jeff ain't working for real.
But like, maybe I could help out.
Oh my, why do we...
I mean, I could help out a little more.
Fuck it.
in this they banned in are we banned in this I can throw a
dome out
I fucking knew that was gonna happen I was like the moment I
swapped the cloak I'm gonna run into a mine guys I did say
the moment I swapped I'm gonna run into the first mine I
see.
This always happens to me.
That's my bad.
I was also sort of looking at chat, so I wasn't looking in
front of me.
This is looking in front of me.
But I was right.
Communication right there.
I just don't think this is working.
I don't think like any of this is working.
oh my god i fucking hate that like the delay i don't know
the timing yet for this
bro can we like push up okay that's fine
oh my god i just got scared
oh god wait
no i think i think our team is cooked guys
Why are we all that?
Because I'm doom queuing.
No, I don't...
This team...
This team might be cooked.
I don't think we can salvage this.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
We are cloak and dagger.
I don't think anything I pick will save us.
Wait, is that a...
Oh.
Are the only...
That's tragic.
Without tie.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Always feels good going into a fight with you.
Keep your cool, Frank.
We're the good guys.
Phoenix team up Wait, we don't have Phoenix is locked We're
gonna go put their vibes here then Oh
Yeah, I was gonna say it's bad I didn't say I was like what
do you mean?
We don't got that here
Oh my god, we gotta kill oh my god.
I've never seen that before oh my god we actually i've never
seen that before in my life how does that feel
what is our string do okay like i am just confused
it's fine we'll just be here oh that's awkward
way I'm just gonna chill here almost gonna chill here wait I
can wait I can do this
all right that's a lot of shit though not gonna lie was
there someone hiding there No, okay.
They are okay over there too.
They are not.
They are 100% not okay.
They are not okay.
They are still not okay.
Yeah, I think I know what I'm avoiding again.
All right, Nance, we did it.
Please!
Make it!
Okay, I made it.
they were above us is he actually above us oh he is you
can't kill him there's a hell above oh my god what the is
going on i'm so confused
but i am just there's just too much i'm getting sensory
overload oh oh no
Oh no!
That is not ideal.
Oh,
it's fine.
Oh, the poor Jeff.
I saw it live.
Oh, man.
That poor Jeff.
it's okay he's blind but only temporarily all right now we
have oh my gosh this guy's playing mystery i will say it
looks like this guy is playing mystery heroes i don't think
even he knows what he wants to play
i don't think he knows what he wants to play right now oh my
god okay
okay i have blinded him he is blinded he doesn't know where
he's jumping right now he doesn't know he's like where am i
jumping i don't know either holy fuck
all right okay if you live here and then we just go this oh
god please let me live
Okay.
I don't have anything else, but good luck, everyone.
Ready?
All right.
Good luck, everyone.
Oh, thank God.
He's actually shielding.
I thought it was over for me.
Man, if only we had a strange en mag during that.
You know, that would have been pretty cool.
I think the game would have definitely been more winnable.
Maybe this game would have been a lot more winnable if we
weren't solo tanking.
Oh, just a little theory I have there.
I don't know.
Is that wild?
Is that a wild...
a pre-assumption where oh um all right that was a stranger
that is a stranger right there i i don't even know what he
did there you go can't see I got us a very very oral right
there it's just that you know what it looks super fucking
cool if I only just killed nobody that would be pretty neat
that would be really cool I'm just trying to probably kill
that oh okay behind you i hope we get rid of that okay we
did uh it's bad bro bro bro okay bro you're just getting
like slapped at
holy i died so fast wait we have a storm since when bro okay
no this guy's actually playing mr hero like when do we get
these guys
we're actually he's actually playing mr hero yeah exploded
hard like he doesn't know what we gotta avoid this guy
Confident of your choice.
Then what's the point?
Okay, I have.
I'm holding.
I've not stopped holding my left.
BP is 1 HP.
He was not 1 HP.
HP but okay.
He was not 1 HP but okay.
That was a...
That was a die.
Oh my god, no, it's over.
It's over.
He was...
He was 1 HP now.
I got three.
He got three.
How?
Swap trench.
Give me a trench.
Oh, never mind.
We can win this league.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh my, I didn't think he would turn around for me.
Oh my god, it's because he was chasing the chest.
I was like, looking at my chat, I was like, oh yeah, I
should be fine.
Oh my god.
That's my bad.
You should know what to have to play, man.
You should know what to play.
I
was like, all right, I should be fine.
Okay, this guy.
Whoa, okay.
Okay.
Okay, let me, let me have a little boy in this guy.
This guy...
This guy was very confused.
I avoided...
Oh yeah, shit.
Shit, I avoided...
I avoided Jeff and...
Mystery Heroes.
And...
Okay, there you go.
Look at Jutes.
Oh, yeah, one of my friends was like, um, asking if, like,
he could get in touch with the, he could get in touch with
the Marwa Rival's desk, because he wants to be like, oh, I
can solve all the issues by if you just give me, my company,
all the third-party organizations for tournaments.
I was like, bro, they will not like that.
They were not, are not going to go with that, bro.
I was straight up.
I was just like, I don't think, um, I don't think they would
give you all the organizations for third-party tournaments.
Yeah.
Because he has experience with organizing tournaments for
other games.
And he's like, I can solve this problem.
But I think, like, the thing is, the community will be,
like, super mad about that.
Because it's, like, gatekeeping.
Bro, wants to be the tempo of Marble Ravos.
say that because it was tempo that ass
way I think like people would be mad though because like
because people would be like oh it's gay keeping you know I
can play game but if we need
pick your hero or villain I'm not judging
oh triple support time oh is gamut open let's go let's
fucking go I'll play gamut in 20 years time to see if your
boy gambit can steal us away 30 seconds before you attack
get ready i want to show them t gambit and loki what what
the oh i don't want to oh against gambit and loki okay i was
like again t gambit against
English is my first language.
Okay, that makes sense, yeah.
I was like, again, I never even met you, bro.
I've never seen you before my life.
I'm gonna say, what do you mean again?
Who are you?
Oh my god, am I gonna have to waste my...
Oh my god, dude.
I have to waste this.
Just because we are so low.
It went a hard dive.
Oh my god.
Everyone needs so much heals.
Reload.
Are you like, Gary?
I don't want to show fucking low.
That sucks.
I want to do it.
I want to anti-black hat.
What?
Oh, that's off.
That's actually awkward.
That's so awkward.
He copied Star Lord.
Alright, well, at least we have Gambit on.
Well, we take, we had two Star Lord olds!
Alright, I'll wait.
This sucks because I can't use it, I can't use this
aggressive.
Okay, we didn't need that, but they'll care.
We did not need that.
All right, well, um, we might be fucked.
We don't have, uh, Mentis ult, oh, and oh, that's awkward.
We might, we might have a little, oopsie.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, you know, it'll be cool that we
had matches out there.
Wait, this guy can play things other than Jeff?
Bro, are you fucking?
Oh, my God.
No, it's okay.
It's all right.
This guy can actually play, like, Can Ashley not play Jeff.
That's Ashley.
Oh my god.
We were solo healing Jeff.
Like
Why couldn't he have character development?
Well, I don't understand.
Oh my god.
I was up in the air.
So I couldn't.
right click down like when he was on my team
why did he cure your development when I was dead all right
it's fine I have load here oh that's unlucky I was gonna see
I can grab all the way do we ban Jeff is that it oh my god
we must have ban Jeff I did not i did not check let me check
if he yeah actually is bad oh my god we did we banned jeff
that's why bro i rather we banned okay i rather we banned
gambit because then he would be like double support with
jeff and
they are not wait they're not triple they're not Ripple.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Oh, I'm like, what the fuck do you mean?
You have three.
I was not healing.
You said you have 3K heals.
You know, I could have got heals.
Like what the fuck do you mean?
He's like, I don't know what's going on.
I'm only datamish boosted.
I only have 3k heals That's still heals What do you mean?
I know what's going on and I'm not healing Like what?
That's still healing Gambit Loki Gambit Loki
No, this is like valid crash out He's like Not healing.
I have only three K heals.
I should have been ambitled.
There you go.
Yeah.
He...
Go now, go now.
Oh, you copied Mantis, I think.
Oh, you fucked up copy three, Domer!
He fucked up copied two times in a row.
I don't know.
I don't know how that's possible.
How did...
Oh my god.
I don't understand how he copied...
His current record is...
I will say his current record is not looking so good right
now.
When it comes to copying.
it's it's it's 2-1 right now it is 2-1 for copies
black ambivill oh my god okay
I'm just gonna wait oh okay all
right there you go Why are you up?
I swear.
Oh my god, I made it.
Why is our low key over there?
I'm so confused!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's got it!
He's got the gamble!
He's got it!
He's actually got it!
I swear to God.
That's actually crazy.
Okay, I have...
Okay, maybe...
I have, uh...
There we go.
I agree we don't mid-fight so...
It's a little like 80% joking before the before you okay.
I should have just go.
Okay, we got one guy.
We got one guy.
Go Gambit.
He has all he has all.
There we go.
They're TPing, they're TPing.
Oh my god, we gotta kill Gambit.
Holy shit!
Where do I go?
Oh
my god, are we TPing?
Are we TPing?
We're TPing.
Wonderful.
winnable
hours famous last words what are these lobbies because all
the fucking players are at the g3 tournament I do not
recognize any of these players I did not recognize any of
these players and everyone is like the vibes ain't it not
like the you know like playing for the Oh, man, I can't even
say vibes no more, bro.
Zaza ruined vibes, man.
Like...
Bro, this whole thing ruined vibes.
Can't even say it for fun no more.
I just got to the point that it's so overdone, too.
That's forever tainted.
I can't even use that word for, like...
Any other game anymore.
Oh, seven vibes.
Oh, the group?
Who the fuck was my group?
I don't have enough of wishlocks.
Where is he?
They ruin vibes forever.
She literally killed the vibes.
Like, no, yeah, exactly!
She killed the vibes!
I can no longer vibe in peace.
It's literally gone.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Very unfortunate.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
What time is it now?
140.
I'll play...
This might be LG.
It might be LG.
Because I do have another stream today.
I don't want to...
I want to play zombie.
these but I'll make the waiting room while we're here yeah
this would be LG what are these lobbies I feel like I'm
playing with like the most random people that I've never
seen before
the quarantine game the zombie quarantine game
you'll need a top-notch team to win this one um what a fuck
do I win this
Let's rock it.
They already cladding really high.
Alright, babe.
Or is the rank reset?
I'm like, I swear to God.
Like, I don't recognize anyone anymore.
I guess like all the everyone else is playing the J3 turn.
You're right.
I think everyone's just actually playing it.
Yeah.
I saw the office is important.
I saw that like since the beginning.
I mean, Eddie is also in Fortnite from Ed, Eddie, and Eddie.
Um, I just don't think Steve Corel looks really good in
Fortnite.
I, yeah, that's just my honest opinion.
I, he just looks like a, just an office.
Like, I mean, it is the office, but he really just looks
like a regular guy at the office.
Like, I know, like, that's the whole premise, but, like,
it's just, like, because, like, because it's like, okay,
because, It's like Dwight has more distinguishable features,
but like Steve Corel, he just...
It doesn't really look like Steve Corel, you know what I'm
saying?
Like, it doesn't really look like him.
But the Dwight one is good.
I think Dwight was really good.
Yeah, he is just a dude, but it's just, you know.
It just doesn't look as funny, you know, when you kill
people with him?
It just doesn't look that funny.
But when you get killed by Dwight, that's funny.
Getting killed by Dwight is funny.
But getting killed by, like, some random office guy is not
as funny.
I guess you could say, yeah, but it could be like some
random office guy with a gun.
Just doesn't give the same ha-ha.
It doesn't give the same ha-ha.
Burr!
Oh my god, protect me, protect me, protect me.
No!
I can't believe he flew that far.
No, I should not have bird.
They made it halfway!
That was unlucky.
I had I burned my last.
I should have just played a little safer there That was my
bet
Um, they are I I can't have anything Can't have anything
Like, it's just me!
No one else is in there!
I can't have anything.
Life is just not fair, I guess.
We went from one hook player to the next.
What is up with all the hook players?
Nope.
That's fine.
I didn't think that was so ahead, but...
i wasn't paying attention
all right oh my god i also don't think hulk is the problem
when we do technically have um we do technically have um you
know we do technically have um iron fist so i i don't think
hulk is the issue here right about now when there's like a
lot of things wrong with this it truly is a million things
wrong with us bro like why I got solo on this he was oh my
oh my god I wanted oh my why me All right, fine, I'll play
cloak.
Look at this.
Like, there's a million things wrong with our comp.
I don't think I am the problem.
It's like, it's like, I'll play, I'll play cloak.
Like you can blame, there's so many things that we should
swap, but it's not me.
Like has nobody said swap off?
Oh, what the?
Okay.
Oh, I swapped out rocket.
Why are we in that room?
Bro, what are we doing?
Oh, I just died.
There's like so many things wrong.
Like, clearly their rocket is worth...
They're playing the same here, their cop as us, too.
Oh my.
Why are you fucking kidding?
Really?
I didn't think we needed that, but okay.
Apparently we do.
I was like, I did not think we needed my ult, but apparently
we do.
Alright.
Okay, so I know they have a stream.
Okay.
I can't I can't save twice.
I can't save you all twice.
I Oh my
god.
Okay, I was gonna say I don't have a second fade.
I
I was like, guys, I do not have a second fade for that.
I already saved us from the fucking Thor.
I can't do it again.
I'm sorry.
All right.
I think I might have to.
Yeah.
All right.
Here we go.
Holy fuck.
I'm fucking leaving.
I died enough.
Well, well, one of us lives at least.
All right, it's five.
All right.
Stand in the stand in the stand in this By the I I can't do
this again.
No Oh my god
Oh my god, that's unlucky Or may God send Bro, I told you
it's not just me Oh, I didn't not get that.
I did not get anything.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Maybe today's just not a rivals day.
I swear to god, majority of my games have been so fucking
weird.
Like, like all these games have been like fucking weird as
hell but even in rank these games have been pretty fucking
weird oh it's true it is the weekend it's just not a dokey
day i mean i did have an actual vet scare today in warning
as god has been invaded yet again but as always no
key 30 seconds before you attack get ready
I don't know have I played on weekend much I don't remember
I don't play as much as I used to
all right here we go wait I think they have They have mag
now so I can't play I don't think I can play cloak And I
could try and then they'll be like swap off cloak They'll be
like okay, because I have no backbone and rank You just be
like okay You're so right you're so right All right, I'll
swap off
And I'm backing up hoping you get here too bro I know the
moment I'm fucking we're so dead we're so dead the moment I
oh he's just gonna bag up me like swap off per yo oh
I don't need it
I don't need it I can't do it again!
I can't do it again!
Wait, he didn't have it.
Well, he didn't have it.
Oh god.
That's fine.
Like, this guy's one, please!
How do I do this?
I don't fucking know.
But it happened.
well they're gonna fucking portal guys you got guys get back
here they're gonna fucking portal guys get back here there's
no yep there it is
oh my my god okay
okay please why can't you just go into my aura what do you
mean that's all i've I've been doing.
What?
Oh, never mind.
I wanted to like lock this up.
I'll let him.
By the eye of Akamoto.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
No way.
I just didn't have a second phase.
I...
I'm alive though Like I'm alive bro that path there was just
like fuck her I heard she's a woman
How do I still not
Like how?
Like I don't understand Fuck this How did I still not get
the up?
I
Literally in front of him Like I don't understand I stood in
front of my gambit
That's why I'm so fucking confused.
I was like, how could that not hit me in general?
I'm so fucking confused.
Fucking flag this fucker.
Bro, please.
Oh my god!
I actually this is my entire that's that's what I did from
that all that's all I did I just did that that's all I did
please let me heal this you have to be very fucking stupid
you are very stupid of a gameplay you you are so fucking oh
my god you're so fucking wow if only if only somebody let me
heal
man if only if only this gambit player actually let me heal
you're so fucking stupid oh my god you're so fucking stupid.
He kept healing and then not letting me build all and then
he dies for it.
Like, it's just a tale of Olives as tab.
Literally, it was just that fuck you, August.
Oh my god, the fucking head over and heal them.
So when they come back.
I mean, he is blinded, so...
I'll fucking let him heal.
Look at that, look at that.
Me.
Oh my god, okay.
That's okay.
I have to heal now because...
And now I'll let him heal.
And I'll heal this guy.
And then I'll let him heal.
And then I'll let him heal so he can build his fucking up.
Oh, and guess what?
He has his ult now.
Whoa!
That's what you can see!
Hey, guys.
There is...
a venom here oh my uh
all right it's okay oh my god i can't push up at all i have
to wait it's all gold in there well i will i will i will i
will i will i will i'm not gonna waste it here but i'll do
it here
Okay, we could.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I couldn't fade.
Jesus Christ.
He actually fucking took me down.
Okay oh my god, actually I'm gonna go rack it.
You can count on me.
I got a plan.
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
I'm here.
Okay.
Chris!
I think that's far enough, right?
Yeah, yeah, it is.
I have to.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, the only issue?
Yep.
I can touch.
I'll play touch.
Oh my god!
Are you fucking kidding?
Oh my god.
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck me, I guess.
Our gambit ran so far away.
I don't know what you guys saw.
Our gambit literally, like, was just god oh shit instantly
targeted our gambit literally was like i'm i'm god he went
he ran all the way back to our spawn like our gambit went to
our goddamn spawn
What the fuck?
Oh, it trusts me wants to play.
Sure, if you want to.
Doing it.
I...
Wait, did I derank?
Oh, wait, I did!
I was like, why is it purple?
I was like, wait, why is my thing purple?
I don't know.
You just said you want to play now?
And I'm like, oh man, I was supposed to LG.
I feel bad.
Yeah, Thor avoid.
Trust me, just DM asking to play a few.
But I don't know if he still wants to.
Because I read DM late.
Lola.
okay that's the doom gear I'm just I'm giving it like giving
it a few more minutes and then if he is off I go I go off
but GG's all right I'll give a few minutes i guess while i
wait i'm gonna make my waiting room right now for the zombie
game uh i'll go make a waiting room right now for the zombie
game let me try and make that waiting room she uh
oh my god oh my god check in for round six start guys okay
They're only on their sixth game for this tournament.
That's looking crazy.
They still have three more to go.
I was just watching it.
They're like, chicken, it begins now for round six.
That means they're still waiting on round seven.
They're only on their second game.
How long am I streaming already?
All right, three hours and they're still on their second
game.
At least I got zombies.
Okay, what else I got?
quarantine zone alright quarantine zone the last check there
it is I've been looking forward to playing this okay this
game is just that it's just like those like simulator like
not simulator like the resource management type deal where
you're like it's like paper please but with zombies I guess
the last the last check okay I swear it's not it.
I swear I'm not bit.
There you go.
Oh, a paper.
Wait, maybe a paper, please.
But zombies.
There you go.
That's a good title.
I swear I'm not bit.
I'm innocent.
All right, let me grab the thumbnail real quick.
Actually, it'll chill game.
i'm not patient zero
uh quarantine zone last check zombies i'm doing my little uh
doing the little hashtag uh thumbnail art is we were just
thumbnail artists for this all right have i retweeted this
yet I'll have it.
I'll treat it then for the thumbnail.
All right.
I have...
Me, the waiting room.
I put it at 6 p.m.
Wait.
Is my voice okay for recording stuff?
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
I'm just... I'm talking in like a normal voice.
My throat is cracky.
Crackly.
Is it crackly?
oh no we got knocked out of the first game i'm just chilling
and i throw it crackly is it
a bit okay then i won't record anything i'll just chill all
right oh nice all right and then i make my waiting room
tweet i make my waiting room tweet as soon as i have my
waiting room thingy out.
Man, Jeff is so confident about High Guard.
This game is so...
Oh, High Guard.
High Guard sent a lot of people to play tests.
Apparently, it's very fun.
Man.
I would like to be a play tester.
Oh, you have to be flown out.
Oh, yeah.
I don't think they would have flown me out.
That's cool, though.
That's cool that they flew a lot of people over to test.
Oh, they flew a lot of Apex players.
I guess because, like, it was made by, like, Apex players.
Not Apex devs.
So they flew a lot of Apex players over to check it out.
I mean, there's a lot of endorsements about it right now.
Yeah.
Oh, I think it's also because I might have like you know my
reaction wasn't very positive but I will eat my words when
we got the to be fair I was looking forward to Titanfall 2
maybe because my reaction wasn't very positive I don't think
they would have invited me because they've been a lot of
small but to be fair I expected Titanfall
hey if kai kai is actually really fucking good i will eat my
words i'll i'll be like damn i'm sorry for doubting you i i
i i treat titan fall 2 as titan fall 1 um because it is the
better game but like now now that i know it's like better
you're like okay if if on monday um if on monday it's
actually really good like i will eat my words and i'll be
like look first first impression wise obviously i didn't
have much hope but now now that i see how now that i see
like oh hey a lot of people are endorsing it right now i
mean the thing is i see like a lot of people endorsing it on
my twitter feed right now a lot of apex players and like uh
um big streamers are endorsing it at the moment being like
oh yeah like i got tested out early yeah that may be good
i'm trusting the words of these streamers a lot of like apex
yeah a lot of apex players got invited to it man i hope so i
want another fps game to but yeah like look at look jeff is
so cocky right now look this you're so fucking cocky right
now trusting streamers you guys trust me um i think you guys
trust me right
right guys all right
right guys i'm trust worthy
I mean, I'm gonna make my waiting room tweet too.
No.
Here's the waiting room.
Time to play.
Zombies, paper, please.
I will make sure new Doki Lod will be a safe haven.
We're all of us.
We like you.
Trust you.
Dang, God.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, nice.
I made it.
I made the waiting room.
New, new, don't worry.
New, new, doki-lan.
We'll be a safe haven for all.
For real this time.
And also, we haven't had a solo stream.
in a while, so this would be our solo stream.
Well, before a while, I'm in for like this week.
Alright.
There you go.
Okay, trust me, he said he's getting on.
Alright.
When is Boker Bash?
That is a good question.
My schedule is all over the place.
I forgot.
Oh, it's not written on the... It is not written on the
server.
I might could leak it.
i could leak who i think guys it's all right people don't
know people it's all right i can leak this like rival play
rival pro streamers don't watch me all right so captain what
no i should i'd be like anyway so captain don't keep no i
got you but oh wait you won one oh it's your birthday osni
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you got me
venti for my birthday happy birthday don't worry i got more
than more than that uh happy oops happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday dear osni happy
birthday to you yeah happy birthday um yeah i'm a captain
for it it's just gonna be content creators i mean i leaked
it a bit during like scrims um let's scream i don't remember
i leaked it a bit i i list some though a little bit um but
it's basically content creators are the captains and then
they assign two pro players for each um they assign two pros
for each team for the captain so the only issue i uh oh he
doesn't have an account okay it's okay we chill now pop um
all right All right.
Oh, he doesn't have an account.
All right.
It's all right.
It was either play a bit more or we relax.
All right.
Apparently I'm too low.
And what does that say?
Um, it's like they're assigned two pros for each team.
But then what the fuck?
Okay.
Fogger lied a little bit to me.
He said it's just most it's gonna be like like content
creators around my level I was like ah, that's cool.
I fuck with that like I guess I was like I feel I feel weird
like being like a captain because I uh feel weird Being
captain because like you know my skill level Yeah, I'm like
to fight around just a little white lie just
look his examples he gave me was big puffer and big puffer
and flats and i was like oh yeah that's like around my level
we don't play that often um as much as like like the main
main i'm like yeah and then i see like and then instantly
and i see the other new captain and i was like wait a minute
it's alright it's like I guess you can't have all content
creators flat's like played every day does he play every day
now I know he like does variety a bit he got me real good he
really did I fell for it again a word because I was like um
um I was like I was like Oh man are you sure I feel weird
being A captain because I don't really I feel like I'd be My
skill level might not be like Up for it And he's like no
don't worry don't worry It's just you'll be fine You'll be a
sign pro player It's like okay I fuck with that
I do be fair Half of the captains Half of the captains are
around my level And the other half of the captains are like
they might be really good they might be half is like my
level and half is like really good like they're sort of
they're also like half contact creators have have like you
know play at really high levels so but Joki fell for it
again she fell for it again
leaking is it fair i guess it'd be fair it would be fair
because it's like 50 50.
and i'll keep falling for it again they'll just be like
don't worry it'll be different this time and i'll be like
really i'll be like really well if you say so i guess i'll i
guess i'll do it
show the old charlie brown and football oh yeah the
tournament's over i'm just chilling it's like a little
distressed chill hour yeah yeah i would it'd be like free
evo for me free elo
gladly come over
but I think it'll be a good tournament because it is there's
a lot of really good players in this well from what I see
right now it's a lot very recognizable people that we all
know sort of I guess not well not you guys might not know I
know I pay attention to rival esports and my rival streamers
um for those who don't know like i don't actually watch a
lot of content creators in general i just i know like i i
i'm pretty boring but i actually just if i watch streams i
just watch uh people play rink i i just watch people play
rink like that's that's really it like whatever game i'm
obsessed with So I don't personally watch like content
creators in general.
I just like to watch.
Yeah, I just like to watch people play rank.
It's not even like personality.
I don't even care if they don't talk.
I just be like, oh, that's cool.
It's like watching sports for me.
Yeah, it's like I just like, it's like for me, it's like my
version of watching sports.
Oh, no, no, he can't get him.
range with me so I'm just I was just like having a little
talk with you guys um because we're trying to figure out
when boker bash 2 is but I forgot when boker bash 2 is I'm
like looking and I'm like there's no info on the discord yet
oh wait is it here oh wait they added it oh my god read oh
there's nothing in here I was like wait they added another
tab and it says read me announcement and there's nothing in
there there's there's nothing in there they haven't added
what the announcement is yet all right you know i'll just
look up boogers twitter and then just to see when it is
she fell for it again when will i stop falling for it it's
next week that's all i know just know it's next week um i
just know it's next week
all right read me nothing
fine for it we'll continue with some morale in prunes all
right all right no more no more stalling no more stalling
i'm gonna go chill a little bit for a couple hours get some
work done behind machines and then when i attempting to get
work done behind machines because i'm always behind behind
work um and then we're gonna play zombies we're gonna play
zombies tonight chill from the rivals stuff um but all i
know is booger bash 2 is next week i don't know when it is
it's it's just somewhere there it's it's stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you step for me head to bed cause you deserve
it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye